[Music]
chuck yes we got earth day in the house
okay you are you are green you were
greener every time i learned more about
you you were more green than i
previously knew you to be as a matter of
fact yes uh yeah though it's a beautiful
thing that yeah that's beautiful but
what concerns me
okay it's like do you remember back a
few years a few years ago there was the
science march on washington i was there
okay i i what deeply concerns me is that
we needed a science march
that should not be necessary all right
so the fact that we haven't a day
committed
to earth that should not be necessary
you're right every day sad every day
should be earth day
that's it's just everyone every day
should be appreciating earth and that is
not how that's been going but the fact
that we have to be reminded of these
things i guess that that's how you got
to do it right yeah right once a year
and
so earth day
um
people just keep talking about save
earth
right earth earth don't care earth right
earth is here with you or and without
you earth is like honey badger
earth don't care
okay
you gonna run away greenhouse gas guess
what earth don't care
you won't be here the earth will be here
earth don't care okay the planet is here
to stay oceans are made of acid now
guess what earth don't care
so all this stuff to save earth what
people really mean
is save life on earth or say us on earth
right so it's more parochial than
say planet earth the planet earth was
here when the asteroid took out the
dinosaurs a rock the size of mount
everest earth was here before during and
after that all right so let me ask you
this since you brought up the dinosaurs
which i find
um kind of
um intriguing by the way if they had a
space program probably they would have
deflected the asteroid and they'd still
be here
yeah and we'd be snacks it's not good
tasty
exactly
scurrying underfoot
did you know the evidence for why they'd
still be here it's no very excellent
evidence okay you want to hear it okay
yes so
uh the dinosaurs
around
for like 200 million a year i've got the
exact number but it's around there
million years
before
the asteroid took him out there you go
and how many years has it been since the
asteroid 65 66 million million years so
they're allowed for longer than the time
that is around since they went extinct
that is exactly what i was about to ask
you but go ahead okay so now here's
what's even better you ready go ahead do
you remember the the the
uh
who's the one with the plates on the
back spine stegosaurus second one
stegosaurus
do you realize the time between
the last appearance of stegosaurus
and the rise of t-rex
is longer
than the time since t-rex went extinct
wow
so in other words we are closer in time
to t-rex than t-rex was to stegosaurus
wow
okay so this is what i'm saying
so
this
they just were unlucky
now so earth day we're trying to protect
earth from our own forces but really we
should be protecting earth from rogue
asteroids as well fold that into
all of the ways we want to protect life
on earth yeah and asteroids are up there
going we did it before we could do it
again we'll take your ass out again
that's right
they're all talking to each other like
okay so apophis give us a report
well i missed him this time i couldn't
get to the keyhole but guess what
next time
i'm shooting
okay i got to tell people what the
keyhole is so
there's certain trajectories where they
don't hit earth
but if they go through this point in
space
earth's gravity can be just right or
rather just wrong
so
next time around it ends up hitting
earth right and you call that a keel if
it comes a little closer then earth's
gravity will swing it harder
swing it farther away a little too
if it misses it the other direction
it'll go too slow so if it's just right
through the keyhole then it will hit
earth so it's an interesting name for it
and i think it's well named but the
keyhole implies there's something you
want on the other side that's definitely
not the case here yeah we don't want to
unlock our impending doom correct yeah
and it wouldn't be a problem if in the
future we have like mining companies
let's say that mine asteroids i've said
many times surely the first trillionaire
will be the person who
exploits the natural resources on
asteroids if they can mine an asteroid
they can probably nudge it out of the
way so we get on the horn and say hey uh
we found an asteroid just discovered in
our deep space network it looks like
it's headed our way could you just hop
over to that and deflect it or take half
of it away
and then he'll say i can
for one trillion dollars
[Laughter]
i forgot that this is a bond villain
story here
and listen
for one trillion dollars exactly
so so yeah protecting earth i think uh
can involve these other these other ways
i mean why not
and so i look forward to the day
where we're so good at this
that we can retire earth day
i mean why not that would be great yeah
because it says that our ever-present
mentality is one where we appreciate it
always
which we should and we know never to
take it for granted right right and
under those situations we wouldn't have
needed earth day in the first place
so true yeah
i don't know what it is about human
beings that makes us take
things that are so necessary for our
survival
for granted
it it's curious to me and i i'm really
puzzled by it like i think about it a
lot it needs better marketing maybe i
mean because people say i don't like
science i don't like space and i don't
like this okay and they'll say you know
i'm i'm fine with my
you know
weather.com and my
right and my directv but i hate space
and i hate this so what you do is you
sneak in in the dark of night and remove
everything from their room
that was inspired or invented by virtue
of space technology and they'll wake up
in a cave yeah they'll wake up naked uh
it can get cold and it could be in a
cave right basically that and so maybe
we need those reminders once a year
that'll happen to you and you have to
re-acquire
all the technologies that you were
taking for granted yeah see yeah you
know what you're that it's i'm yeah
you're absolutely right because even
when you think about the burning of
fossil fuel it's greed that that has
that has driven that for many many years
well greed drives so much of everything
but that greed in particular
had consequences right i mean greed is
greed as greed and that's what oh my god
you sound like gordon gekko right now
green is greed is good
[Laughter]
greed is good yes
but i'm saying this if people if
everyone were scientifically literate
even the greedy would always look for
better ways to make money so even if i
were the guy who owned uh the oil
company this is my point my being
scientifically literate would say well
this is really an inefficient way for me
to power stuff and it's only a matter of
time before it's obsolete let me look
forward and i'm gonna invent this now
and because i'm greedy because i'm
greedy yes exactly exactly now let me
let me try to make um all these other
power sources affordable and cheap and
easy because then i will become rich for
doing so because i'm greedy right so you
just have to shift the greed vector
into the green direction
and maybe that's not what not enough
people are thinking to do that because
they think that any greedy capitalist is
necessarily anti-green and it might
start out that way but ultimately
they're all gonna have to switch that
around oh yeah that's right and they
kind of did it is it called mobile oil
company anymore i don't think so i don't
think so either all right the oil was
taken out of all of those names yeah
okay yeah no yeah exxon is not exxon oil
or it was actually taxon mobile right
right not mobile
and they're they see themselves as
energy companies so they're they're
getting ready they're priming the pumps
for this future yeah yeah so yeah
that's fine so listen here you granola
birkenstock hippie wearing
suckers
get on the game and let's get some
capitalism so we can end this this this
global warming thing because only greed
only greed is going to help us okay
sitting around on earth and crunchy
while we all die
okay
put put your tie dye down
okay
stop smoking your weed for a second and
let's get on this let's make some money
on this damn it that's the only way we
gonna win
that's a whole other outlook right there
i should write an op-ed with that
point of view exactly greed is good
greed is good let greed save the earth
dog
greed and green baby green and green
let's make it happen
all right check that's that's going to
be our earth day
or our earth day deposit into the into
the
the din of everyone's chance
of how we need to save earth going
forward there you go all right all right
that chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
[Music]